[Music]
hey y'all time for another matinee show
and just like earlier in the week we're
doing yet another documentary I don't
know how we ended up doing more
documentaries this week because the
documentary looks good that's just what
we ended up seeing yeah that's good
there's a lot of documentaries yeah I do
too this one was also another one that
we rented off of Xbox yeah yeah and this
is a 20/20 I think it just came out May
5th yeah it was cheap it's on like $2.99
399 but it was what it was worth seeing
yeah it's called the house in between
yeah house in between is kind of a
haunted house taking place in of all
places Mississippi right outside yeah
we're outside Jackson and it was a good
documentary kind of like kind of like a
higher-end version of something of kind
of like taps or something
yeah it was I was gonna say it wasn't
like um ghost hunter what's the one with
Zach okay so it's not as cheesy as that
it's a lot you know you can tell the
budgets a lot higher you know it looks
like a lot better shot and it's not as
like over the top that was one thing
that I kind of liked about this you know
documentary and we've talked about kind
of paranormal shows in the past ow
sometimes I can't really watch him
because it's they're so cheesy it's like
they wandered around this place and did
you hear that I feel cold did you know
yeah so it's like this one didn't have
too much of that um so there's this
house in Florence Mississippi and the
weird thing is what it's not an old
house the woman that lived there Alice
Jackson she actually had it built I
believe in the early 90s yeah so she
said that weird [ __ ] started happening
like even before the house was finished
I think right so they say it's probably
the land yeah that's kind of what they
were asserting and it's interesting
because she she had a couple of things
happen
that we've had happen here like the
thing where with the door opening and
like the you know the deadbolt still be
knocking out like we've had that happen
in our house Royall
but she had that happen like really
early on so this documentary is kind of
about I mean they talked with her a lot
and like all this
that happened there and then they had
like all these different crews come in
and like film so the bulk of it is this
one um this one two-man team and they
come in and they set up cameras all over
and everything like that and then later
they get that guys you can't remember
what it's dam name it's not Zack it's
the other guy from taps right yeah I
think he's from taps
I think he is the first team where
locals they're from Mississippi yeah
they're different from that area and and
you know he was he heard about it on the
news
he's on the local that's right yeah so
he was like man that's here ya know and
he went down there contacted he did the
investigation so it's Adam
dark it's a documentary about two
paranormal investigations of a house
that has paranormal stuff going on and
it seems to be some kind of mild
haunting or perhaps like mild
poltergeist type case it I liked it it
was it was just ambiguous they did get
some stuff on video balls rolling plates
going on like yeah worse opening by
themselves so yeah yeah it's not the
same you couldn't fake that using thread
yeah you could you could fake that'd be
fair but I believe something you know
just based on the woman's testimony you
know she was afraid to be in the house
yes she would stay in there during the
day but I don't think she sleeps there
anymore yeah so something was going on
there yeah it was a good documentary and
I like that they didn't um they didn't
really feel the need to overdramatize
anything like I've seen some reviews of
it like some people who were into the
paranormal like really really liked it
for that very reason because they didn't
over dramatize anything but if you're
expecting something like a fictional
movie I can see how maybe you would
think it was kind of like dull cuz it
seems like not a lot happens it's just a
realistic account of paranormal yeah yes
and so if you want it if you want to
know what the what an investigation is
really like and what your average kind
of haunting is really like this is kind
of what you want to see yes they don't I
mean the only things that I wish they
hadn't done and I think that they did
this on the behest of the taps guy was
like bring up medium in which and
standard thing that the it is
scientific yeah it's just so subjective
it's like you don't know like the
psychic always comes in and says you
know oh they didn't know anything about
this house I'm like you can't prove that
you don't know that they didn't Google
the [ __ ] before because the woman had
been on the news and everything like
that so it would be very easy to like
find [ __ ] out before you went there what
I thought was more more impressive was
the idea they brought cadaver dogs yes
because there was kind of more yeah I'm
interesting I think cuz the cadaver dogs
did seem to think that there were bodies
in that area or had been like a long
time ago and a few followers of the show
you would know that you know I've had
you know poltergeist event in my life
and there was like another house that I
was in later on and me and my friend
were in after we got out of the army
that we thought there was something
wrong with that house and you know I
kind of forgot where I was going with
[Laughter]
anyway yeah go ahead yeah no I was gonna
say something about us guys were you
gonna say something about Mississippian
about some yeah yeah yeah exactly that's
I knew exactly Osama I figured that's
where were you yeah if you if you knew
if you've seen any of the other shows or
I was on my grant or my step-grandfather
it was from Laurel Mississippi he was in
the cemetery business alright and he
owned [ __ ] black cemetery and just
and that was something that went on for
a long time
black cemeteries and [ __ ] poor white
people cemeteries there's no telling
where they are yeah they went happen
with that cemetery that he owned is when
it went out of business later on just
became overgrown it was on worthless
land at the time it ended up in City
hands and probably something built over
it now yeah alright yeah the way they
kind of you know way Mississippi was
yeah now government organization and
paperwork weren't really kind of like a
priority it's very plausible that you
know the mean [ __ ] a cemetery would
get abandoned
and then later on headstones would get
scavenged yeah did turned into something
else
or they were sold off by the prior oil
owners or the new owner would [ __ ]
sell off the the headstones and [ __ ]
Salvage um you know turn them into sent
a concrete company or something
something like that and then trees grow
over it and then it's changes hands a
couple times and then it's forgotten
that that place was ever a cemetery and
you could build houses on top of it the
bodies probably mostly long gone because
and those are you know in lower-income
and lower-income cemeteries of those
days they didn't do a lot of embalming
they just straight-up buried them in a
pine box or sometimes even just a
cardboard box yeah you know so within no
matter of a few months you know it's
just a skeleton and then you know
groundwater the way it is you know the
skeleton itself might be gone so is it
still a cemetery I don't know but those
cadaver dogs would be able to pick up on
that because it gets in the trees it
gets in the plants and [ __ ] evidently
well that's what they said on here like
that it seems pretty plausible isn't
very possible if there had been like
cadavers there at one point if it had
been a cemetery and trees had
subsequently grown through where the
bodies were then it's not crazy to think
that dogs would still be able to like
smell that because their sense of smell
is so good yeah if you're up north or in
us in an City area the idea of building
something on top an old cemetery might
freak you out but I think I'm pretty
much everything in Mississippi in the
South is built over somebody's dead body
I think everything in the United States
is probably built over somebody's dead
by yeah actually actually let's extend
that to the whole entire world yeah lots
and lots of people lots of people have
died in the imagery of the world so I do
kind of feel like even though I do like
that in this case because she
specifically said that she thought that
there was something wrong with the land
and not the house because she started
experiencing weird things before the
house was even done was that so I do
like that they brought cadaver dogs in
but that said it's like if you know I I
don't believe in like ghosts
haunting type stuff but you know if that
was the case than you think everywhere
would be haunted yeah there would be
dead people yeah and the land here is
much older than the United States and
it's older than what people think it is
it's just nothing like my [ __ ]
uneducated damn Mississippi ask her her
mother with had a damn when she back in
the 70s bought a newfangled [ __ ]
invention called a metal detector
she went into a dried-out lake bed and
was just fine and stuff in the bottle
and one of the things she found in a
dried-out lake bed was a coin a one
dense skilling dense skilling one dense
he's killing the date on it was like
sixteen thirty something like that yeah
yeah my dad has it sixteen thirty
Mississippi what the [ __ ] is that dense
skilling doing in Mississippi in the
1600s I didn't know I guess that's
danish dansk eschewing yeah I guess I
guess it would be Danish and there's
Danes in the 1600s in Mississippi how
the hell do I get there you know like
that's not I mean there it could have
been like traded somebody could have had
it the Indians maybe had it yeah
possible like I said there's all we
don't know like what the what every
single like transaction back then and
it's like could've been a [ __ ] ship
full of Danish traders and well it
couldn't have been a ship because it was
in a lake was gonna try it out lake bed
hmm wonder if it came from because in
life like off that was near near Laurel
Mississippi interesting well hey we
could what's up K what you didn't put
your button but in there for these guys
but so and you you'd be out digging and
you know it's a masonite corporation
logging land putting some kind of a deer
stand you know and find a hole medicine
bottle from the 1800s mid 1800s did I
put the [ __ ] this doing out here dad
you know I'll do my dad's voice
everywhere around here - something was
here before his my better neighborhood
so yeah and that's probably exactly what
happened like where this woman
where this woman built her house like I
said she didn't build it until like the
90s so there's no tellin what was there
like a hundred years ago 200 years ago
something like that yeah um I
it wouldn't be crazy to think that there
was like a bunch of dead people out
there somewhere an old spirit like an
old burial ground or something I don't
think it was necessarily somebody who
got murdered no righteous old burial
ground but yeah but so it you know it's
it's interesting in the sense that it's
not like super scary or anything like
that but it's interesting in the sense
that at least they're just doing like a
pretty standard paranormal investigation
I mean if you like shows like a haunting
or you know paranormal state or whatever
you'd probably be really into this it's
not they do capture like some
interesting things on camera that like I
said could have been faked but it's you
know it's still a good documentary it's
still like entertaining to watch yeah
I'm not saying that it was faked I'm
just saying it's possible that you if
you would say you guys I think it was
probably real yeah I think it was
probably real so it's nothing like
mind-blowing but like it is like creepy
like the doors shutting in the image at
one door the way it shut it kind of
looked like the way that door shutting
in there they went yeah there were from
the laundry room to the garage we had
that happen though yeah that was another
thing that I forgot to mention right
kind of looked like that was it she
wasn't shutting slowly and it wasn't
shut and quickly there was like a weird
in-between way I should just yeah weird
it reminded me to like all the [ __ ] that
she had with her with her lights and
everything and she had an electrician
like a bunch of electricians come in and
check it out and I guess they couldn't
find anything but it reminded me of that
part in poltergeist where they were
sitting at the table with the paranormal
investigators and the light went like
flash like that and then they said oh
they'll be two more in a couple of
minutes like that a couple seconds like
they always come in pairs or whatever
and it kind of reminded me of that but
yeah so it's like like I said it was
only like $2.99 or 399 I rent this if
you're into paranormal [ __ ] or like
poltergeist [ __ ] or anything like that
and you like any of those type of TV
shows then this is a pretty good it's
kind of like a slightly higher budget
version of that yeah and I think I think
slightly more credible of course yeah
and not as you know no you can tell that
they're not trying to like make us
super-exciting like show every time
which I actually kind of liked about it
yeah I mean I can see how some people
might think I was like boring cuz
nothing happened but it's stuff did have
stuff did happen it's just that they
didn't try to build it up into something
that it wasn't which I kind of think
they were just trying to show what the
case was and what it really happened
yeah because this has been ongoing I
guess the she's had she's had people in
and out of there for like ten years and
she's been on the news and stuff so I
guess it's a fairly famous case although
I hadn't heard of it up until now
but you know so like I said it's called
the house in between you know it's on
streaming services just chaos what is
worth seeing yeah it's definitely worth
seeing so uh during the paranormal stuff
so check it out
[Music]